Hey guys. How's it going? It's Justine.
Today we are going to be checking out some new
Nintendo Switch accessories.
It's not a secret that I'm obsessed with my Nintendo Switch--
still--yes-- I'm still obsessed.
I now, officially, have beat Zelda,
I ended up beating Gannon on the plane and it was
kind of awkward because I had no one to celebrate with.
I really did want to wait until I was home to beat it but,
I basically had five hours to kill on the plane
and I thought "Now's the time".
Anyway, lets check these out and you guys can be
can be on your way onto the next video
after you're done watching this.
The first thing I wanted to show you was...
This.
This is a hand-made, leather, Nintendo Switch bag,
made in San Francisco,--
did I mention, "Hand-Made"--
The place is called: "Water Field"?
sfbags.com..
So someone tweeted me saying , "The Game Over Greggy
recommended this" and that I "should get it".
And then I went to take a look at the bags and I was like
"Wow, these are pretty awesome."
They have a bunch of different options and color combinations
but this was the one I went with because I feel like black is my favorite color.
So its got this really nice, little zipper back here.
Its a nice little mesh.
So you can put, like, some cords, or--really whatever else
you want to put in here.
I mean, I can actually put my phone in there,
or wallet.
I mean, this could essentially be a purse.
[Zips zipper]
Like, I don't want to stray guys away from getting this, but,
I mean, this is a nice clutch-
like this is, this looks good.
They also give you some options of accessories
that you can get with it.
And I am such a sucker for all of these clips
because I use these for everything.
I clip them on my purse -- I use them when I walk the dog--
I love being able to hook tons of different things
on.
So I think this was, um-
[Clip clatters]
[Shocked expression]
When you're at the checkout, it gives you the option
to add these onto your bag.
So these were the different accessories that you could add on.
You could add this clip, you could add the leather strap,
or this matte black clip-
I don't remember exactly what they were called but,
you'll see on the website if you decide to get this--
And this clips off just like so.
So its got places to put your games right here,
which are very nice.
Although, I plan on doing as many, all digital games as possible.
So if you could see inside here, there's a bunch of different, little pockets as well.
Put this in there,
fits,
like a glove;
and it actually fits quite well.
And its got these little...
magnetic buttons here..
[Snaps buttons]
This is a really good-lookin bag.
And its nice and padded in here as well so,
I feel like,
even if you put this inside of another bag,
or... you do end up wearing it sort of as a
wristlet type thing,
it will have some padding and protection.
Next up are these little...
What are these?
These are headphones.
So, Nintendo sent me this,
the backpack and this case to check out.
So, thank you Nintendo, I appreciate it
because I have definitely bought way too many
Nintendo accessories for the Switch.
Let's check these out, these are
Zelda case and chat earbuds.
[Rips open package]
Oh that's cute!
So this has, like, the little area to put your headphones in;
and you can wrap the cable around there to keep them
nice and neat.
These  look pretty good!
Yeah, just pop that in there.
Ok, I'm going to be completely honest with you,
this is taking too much time. [Chuckles]
I feel like I'm never gonna just...roll these up again.
Sarcastically: "Wow!"
"Suuper official!"
Next up is this case,
my friend, Joy, actually had this one...
[Opening package]
I mean, if this doesn't say, "Hey! I got a Nintendo Switch in here!",
I don't know what does.
I do think, I prefer, having a more subtle case.
So if you're out and about, and somebody sees it, they're not, like,
"I'm stealing that. That's a Nintendo Switch in there."
[Rips more packaging]
So this has all kinds of accessories though.
So these have some little bumpers that you can put on
your Joy-Cons.
Talk about decked-out!
Got these little things that you can put on your
head-... well, I don't know what those are.
[Click]
Wow. That snapped in pretty quick.
I think that the blue might look a lot better on...
the grey Joy-Cons.
Can you imagine having white Joy-Cons?
Absolutely beautiful!
[Unzips bag]
Let's take a look inside.
Oh! It comes with a nice,
protective cover!
And--oh this is good because, the one that I put on,
I did a very terrible job and there's bubbles in it.
So it looks like this just has a little velcro thing.
Attach your Switch--
You definitely have a little bit of extra room there so,
be warned.
I think that's one of the complaints that Joy had. She felt like
it didn't fit perfectly, where some of the other cases
do have a much tighter fit.
But, there is a lot more room in here for pretty much anything.
Actually, you can probably put your Switch even in there.
Yeah. This looks good.
[Zips case]
Still not quite sure what these are fo--
Oh, I know what they--they're for this!!
They're the top of the [stammers "the"]...the controllers!!
I mean, that doesn't really look good in this color combination.
I mean, if that's something your into...
go for it.
Now that I have really been waiting for is
checking out this Nintendo Switch backpack.
It even has a Nintendo Switch logo on it?
*sighs*
So on the front, we got this nice little zipper;
opens up quite nicely to have some more little...
zip places...to put things--zip places to put things-- what?
So inside the main zip pocket, it has two other zippered areas,
to put your items.
Let's look inside.
[Unzips backpack]
So here's one main, little pocket area--
I wonder if I can fit my laptop in here?
There's a lot of places to put things here.
Oh, wow!
This is overwhelming.
There's also another zipper up here too to put stuff in.
It's crazy. There is...
Wo-- there is so many pockets.
Like, how many controllers do they think that we're gonna have?
There's one,
two,
three, four,
five, six-- there's like, six slots,
to put Joy-Cons in.
It's quite nice right there.
Put your Pro Controller there...
Joy-Con slot-- *whispering* they got so many!
So something that will be super important for me is:
will I be able to fit my laptop in it?
Let's see.
I happen to have it sitting right here.
Oh, yeah. I mean, there is so much room.
Look at that. This is a 15 inch laptop.
You can put it here,
you can put it here--
There's a lot more room in this thing;
a lot more room than I thought.
Also, really well made.
[Zips backpack]
The zippers: quite responsive;
Which is, a great quality in a zipper,
let me tell you
because, I have had some backpacks that I've bought
that were actually super expensive and I was like,
"This is a crap zipper!"
"What is this!?"
I have not a single complaint about this backpack.
If you were gonna get any of the things that
I talked about today,
this is it.
This would be my number one favorite.
I actually like this backpack
way more than my um,
expensive, hand-made leather bag.
Mostly because I like to carry with me
absolutely everything.
And with this, I can.
With this, it's basically
just my Switch,
some little accessories and things like that;
but, I mean, I can even put my Switch
in here,
then put it wherever I want.
This is nice.
Feel like this would be an everyday bag
and then maybe if I'm going to like,
a nice, fancy red carpet,
or, like, a party,
this would be my bag that I would take.
[Transition]
So, to celebrate the launch of Mario Kart,
I'm actually going to play some Zelda right now,
but, after I play Zelda,
I'm going to play some Mario Kart.
So this is kind of, like, a three-in-one video:
we've got an unboxing,
we've got Zelda gameplay,
and Mario Kart.
So, what better way to celebrate, then,
then this?
And I really haven't been playing as much as I was
before, thankfully, because I was so obsessed and
disgusted with myself *Chuckles*.
I was like: "You got to go outside,"
"you got to get videos done,"
"you got to get work done,"
"you can't just be sitting on the couch"
"doing nothing".
And, I wasn't doing nothing.
I was saving Hyrule.
So, where am I now?
I don't remember where I left off.
I still have a lot of shrines to get.
[Chuckles softly]
Sorry, horsies, I scared you.
Did I scare you?!
Is there any shrines over here?
There's gotta be something.
Can you stop raining, please?
Is there anything special over here?
There's gotta be something over here.
Where's all the freakin' shrines at?
[Lightning strike]
Geez, oh my goodness!
Well, I'm just walking around a lot...
Get away! Get away! Get away!
Oh, god!
Ah!
Can it stop storming already?
I got stuff I got to climb.
Get away from me! Get away from it!
Get--stop it! Leave me be!
[Link slashes enemy]
Ooh, you're fierce.
[Link slashes enemy repeatedly]
*Sheepishly* My Guardian Sword is damaged?
Can you believe I just--I just died
like, trying to beat this piece of garbage guy?
You're fierce.
I haven't died in this game in so long,
and that's how I go out?
That's how I go OUT!?
You're--
I was wasting my time anyway!
Ok, we're going somewhere else because,
clearly, this area sucks and I hate it.
Ok, so where am I right now?
Oh!
Tarrey Town! I think I was supposed to do something...
Let's go check in and see how it's doing.
*whew*
That was so close.
This town is coming along
*singsongy* "niicely"
"Need homes"?
"20 bundles of wood"?
I think I have wood!
Do I not have enough wood? Shoot!
I don't have enough wood!
Ok, Mr.Man! I'll better bring you some wood.
Yeah, I'll cut the trees down in my own town.
Cut--
[Chuckles slightly]
Cut it!
*Australian accent* "I need two more!"
*Regular accent* "Hey, why not use an axe, Justine"
Because, I'm an idiot.
And, I don't think I have one.
I don't. I guess I'll just use my Master Sword.
Why not?
Wow!
That was a beastly hit!
Did I...
I did my math wrong.
Shh.
Guess what, sir? Now I got enough wood for you.
Yes!
Yes! I have them!
Look, I'm soaking wet.
"Gift for tailoring"?
[Incomprehensible]
What?
Where am I supposed to find that person at?
Let's go
search for somebody
who can be a tailor!
Let me put on my sssexy lady outfit.
Ooh! Look at me!
Hello! Call me!
Get out of here--it's not your name-- I need nothing from you.
I need somebody whos last name is "Sun".
"Something Sun"
How bout' you?
"Jules"?
Where is "Something Sun"?
[Background]: "Hey!"
Oh! *gasp*
There is, like, a passcode place
over here that I don't know what the passcode is.
I'm gonna--I'm cheating.
Gotta look it up.
Ok, so here's the place I need a password for.
*sigh*
"G-S-C-Diamond". I'm cheating.
"G"
"S"
"C"
"Diamond"
Every time I've done that before,
its been wrong,
so I had to wait until, like,
the next day, and then I forget.
So I was like, "There's no way I'm forgetting about it this time".
We're goin' for it.
Oh.
*Long gasp*
Look.
I don't think I have enough money.
Oh my gosh is there some cool stuff here?
Look at this!
*Gasp* How much is it?
"Trade materials"?
Oh my god!
Yes!
800 Rupees.
Give it to me!
This is beautiful!
And, it was cheap!
Now I got to figure out what I was actually doing
in the first place.
Ok, bye! Have fun! Thanks!
*Whisper* "Yes!"
I'm beautiful!
Come on, I got something for you.
I'm so excited, come on!
Please! Please, please! Go to my town!
And that's it.
Tarrey Town, my new princess.
Ok, let's go see our,
our grown Tarrey Town.
That's--no-no-no-no that's not where I wanted to go!
It's the fairy.
Do you have any houses yet?
I gave you all my wood,
I gave you my wood and my promise,
*Australian accent* "Hello. Aww, look at that little doggie."
How's it goin'?
Do you need more wood?
Oh.
30...bundles of wo--oh dear goodness gracious
I'm gonna have to get to work on that one.
Hey, girl!
Look at this.
oh my.
Look at your beautiful wears!
No, I don't want to sell anything. I wanted to say hi.
But, I didn't read what you said to me.
Well, that's Tarrey Town.
Uh, I didn't really accomplish much in this episode.
I guess I'll go find him some more wood or something.
But, I sort of [incomprehensible]
So I'm gona go eat, and then when I come back,
its gonna be, *Snaps* just like that,
I'm gonna play some Mario Kart.
So, see you in two seconds.
-Are you ready, Jen? We're gonna play some Mario Kart.
-Jen: Yeah, I gotta sync up.
-Justine: Ooh. I don't know who I wanna be.
-Jen: Yooshi!
-Justine: Maybe Pink Yoshi?
[Both imitating Yoshi]
[Both laugh]
-Jen: Somethin' fun.
-Justine: Ooh, this looks fun.
-Jen: *Gasp* Rainbow Road!
-Justine: Oh, god, let's do it!
-Jen: Oh gosh, that's what nightmares are made of.
-Justine: It really is.
-Jen: But, it's so fun, but it's
scary at the same time.
-Justine: Cloudtop Cruise!
I have a big disadvantage because there's a camera
oh-ok-good, its split screen like this. So, that's fine.
[Both imitate "3-2-1 Go" signal]
-Jen: Oh! I'm backwards again
every time.
-Jen: *English accent* Oh my goodness! I'm so sorry!
-Jen: Man!
-Justine: Ooh, this one's fun.
-Jen: Yeah. It's fun when you're going in the right direction.
[Justine laughs]
Jen: I like, actually...
-Justine: What?
-Jen: Nothing.
-Justine: What's wrong?
-Jen: Oh I'm seventh, so...
-Justine: Oh.
-Justine: Oh I just got shocked.
Jen: Are you?
-Justine: Now I'm in Seventh.
I should have did a couple warm-ups before we played.
Jen: Glad you didn't because last time
that's what happened and you guys beat us.
Justine: Why did you do that to me?!
Jen: I don't think I did.
Justine: Well, whoever did it...
Jen: Oh goodness gracious!
[Both gasp]
Justine and Jen: Oh no!!
Jen: Did we all get it?
Justine: I think we did.
Justine: What place are you right now?
Jen: Second.
Justine: Oh.
Jen: Yeah.
Justine: That's ok. I'm proud of you-oh shoot. I just hit a bananna.
[Cross talk]
Justine: ...so bad.
Jen: Last lap.
Jen: A coin. A coin is not gonna save me from these-
Justine: The coins do give you a bit of a boost.
Jen: No, no, no, no, no. Don't-don't ink me.
Justine: Aaaaaaaahhhhhh.
Jen: Please don't ink my screen.
Jen: I need to get...
Justine: ...so bad.
Jen: I need to get to the finish line now.
[Jen gasps twice]
Jen: If I had my phone, I'd take a pic.
Justine: Shoot!!
Jen: ♪I got first place♪
Justine: Uh, hello in fifth.
Justine: That's ok.
Jen: Hey, that's not last
Jen: It's not first.
[Cross talk]
Jen: What if I go the right direction this time?
Jen: I mean, I literally started off that race going backwards.
Justine: You did.
Jen: I do it every time.
Justine: Why?
Jen: I don't know why.
Jen: Why do I do anything that I do?
Justine: I don't know.
Jen: Justine.
Justine: I got to focus.
Justine: I'm getting a little better with my turns
Jen: I'm getting dizzy
Justine: Oh!
Jen: Hey, I almost shelled myself.
[Justine chuckles]
Jen: It's not funny.
Justine: I'm sorry.
Jen: *Gasps* Oh no! Is that you?
Justine: What happened?
Jen: I got hit-- Oh! I got two hits!
Jen: Oh my--ok-- well, you know what?
Justine: What'd you get hit by?
Jen: Everything. Everything and everyone.
[Cross talk]
Jen: I did it again! I'm in seventh!
Justine: Oh, that was me actually.
Jen: So like, a million people just hit me?
or three.
Jen: Oh my--oh.
Justine: Gosh, I tried to go over there and wouldn't let me.
Why would you not let me do what I wanted to do?
Jen: Because, not everything is about you, Justine.
Justine: Neeee!
Jen: Ah.
Jen: I'm getting nervous.
Because I don't like to lose.
Justine: Me either. But, I do play often so,
it's kind of like I'm fine with it.
cause, you got to be ok with it.
If you do it often.
Jen: *quietly* awkward
Jen: Well I'm in first,
So, you're in second so I'm not in first.
Justine: This is...
this is tight.
Jen: This is a close race.
Jen: Oh my gosh. Why'd I do that?
Justine: Why would I do that?
Jen: [Says "Why would I do that" repeatedly]
Why did I just do the thing that I just did?
Justine: Aaah!
Jen: Am I even going the right direction? I don't even know!
I feel like I was going backwards.
Jen: Man, this sand is tough.
Justine: It sucks!
I'm not even on the track. Or, is that how slow I'm supposed to be--
[Takes a sharp breath in]
Justine: Oh my goodness!
Jen: No no no no no no
Justine: Oh my goodness!!
Justine: No no no no no! Third place!
Jen: I was in first the whole ti-?
[Jen pretends to throw controller]
Jen: I was in first the whole time.
[Jen groans in frustration]
Justine: I know, man, I know.
Mario Kart. Mario Kart logic: unfair!
Jen: I better...
Justine: You're still...
Justine: You're still above me.
Jen: No. I need to be the best.
Justine: Wait, look at that map.
[Laughs gently] Its nuts.
Jen: That...is...
Justine: Oh, I remember this one. It's not bad.
I mean, it's not easy...
There are so many freakin' turns.
Jen: Man, that's the thing I'm freakin' worst at.
Jen: So, basically the whole game.
Justine: Oh no, no, no.
Justine: My acceleration is very.. more!
Jen: What is that noise?
Justine: What? Where? What?
Jen: Say they had a wind. [?]
Justine: AAH!
Justine: Nooo!
Jen: Oh, geez.
Justine: This is hard.
Oh god! I'm getting crushed by rocks?!
Jen: What are these lasers?!
Lasers?!
Justine: I don't know man.
Jen: Oh.
Justine: Woah, laser city. Oh my god, I just got cut.
Jen: Oh ok, I hit myself and then...
Justine: Why'd you hit you so hard?
Jen: Well because, I'm so excited.
Jen: Get out of my way!
[Both say noooo softly]
Jen: How'd you get in third?
[Cross talk]
Jen: I hit the rock. A lot of people hit the rock.
Jen: One more lap? Oh wow, I need to get...[something]
Justine: Wow. It's true. So much can happen.
Jen: ♪Got Lasers and Whats-its galore.♪
[Justine chuckles]
Jen: Well, everything's upsetting right now-ooh I'm in second.
Well, how I go around?
Justine: This is so upsetting.
Jen: Yeah, it really is.
Jen: I feel like I'm tilting my whole body to like-
Justine: You are.
[Justine laughs]
Jen: To try to make more...
Justine: Tilt tilt tilt!
[Cross talk]
Jen: Don't worry about what I'm doing, worry about yourself!
Jen: GEEEZ!
Justine: That was you?
Justine: OMG! No! No no no NOOO!
Everything is NOT AWESOME!
Stupid!
MAN!!
Jen: I was in first,
second
and now I'm turned around and I'm in sixth,
ahead of me...
Jen: Why?
you...I think you're the reason why...
Justine: Hey, you're still beating me.
Jen: So like, how many times will I fall off the map?
Justine: Oh my gosh.
Jen: *quietly* oooh
Justine: *quietly* ooh I'm gonna...
Jen: It's like still remember. Was it the Nintendo 64?
Justine: mmhmm.
Jen: Oh. Such a fun time.
Justine: Yeah. Life was good. Life was grand. I was small.
Justine: You were even smaller.
Jen: Yeah, I was.
Justine: You were a little baby.
Jen: Well, I don't think I was That small enough.
Justine: Uhh,
Justine: Yeah. You were.
Jen: Maybe. I guess I--
Justine: I used to actually play this in your room because that's where one of the TV's were.
Jen: wow.
[Something] heat of that.
What heated when you were a nerd?
"Get out. I wanna play."
Jen: I'm dizzy.
Justine: Me too.
Jen: I'm upset.
I need to chill. I need the rocket.
Just give me the rocket.
Justine: I haven't got that in a long time.
Jen: Ok, well, I just blew myself up so i'm an idiot.
And then someone hit me. Oh my goodness.
Justine: Ooh.
Justine: Oh my gosh, one more lap.
Jen: Well...I just hit two bananas
Justine: TWO bananas. Baneeners.
[Justine says different sounding words of "Banana" repeatedly]
Jen: He scored a goal tonight.
Justine Good for him.
Jen: The one that made us win.
Justine: Oh-Oh-yeah, OK, Of Course!
That's b- that is the biggest
That is the biggest bunch of crap that I have ever seen!
Jen: What?
Justine: I was in first place,
then all of a sudden it hit me at the last second!
This is absolutely..
Jen: Welcome to my last couple races.
Justine: ...Unfair!
Justine: This game is such...
Justine: Aw!
Jen: You still got in second.
Justine: Ok-
you got fourth.
This mi--whats it gonna happen?
Jen: You won.
Justine: *gasps* wow.
Justine: Oh my gosh. Only by one.
We didn't even...
Place the top three.
Jen: So we both lose.
Jen: Ugh!
Justine: I have arthritic fingers and body.
Justine: Well guys, thanks so much for watching
we had a fun time playing this but, man, I'm
like, losing my voice already from yelling.
Jen: I'm very upset... I need to win.
Justine: I'll see you guys later.
I hope you guys enjoyed Mario Kart.
Let me know what you guys been playing;
Let me know what you guys think about the cases
that I showed you at the beginning of this video.
I finally unboxed the um, Nintendo Switch backpack?
Jen: Oh!
Justine: It's so nice.
Justine: It's incredible
Jen: Yeah, I've been looking at it here.
Jen: For awhile.
Justine: I know. That was awhile ago.
We'll see you guys later. Byyye!
Jen: Goodbye!
Justine: Where's Maddie?
Jen: I don't know!
Justine: *English accent* Oh, the doggie. Bye Bye!
[Music]
♪♪